it's time to get down to business all
right all right dirty business down to
business
oh my goodness New York City is
concerned that young people want to be
making love the only problem is we're in
the midst of the pandemic and if you
make love
during the corona virus pandemic why you
increase the chances that you will so if
you want to have make love I love to
yourself you got to slow down when you
say it Big Love
I'm sorry or do also lower your voice or
your voice I notice I make love well if
you want to make love make love to
yourself welcome to New York everybody
stop loving from the Daily Mail you are
your safest sex partner NYC officials
publish guide to intimacy during
coronavirus pandemic with advice this is
not a good time to be having orgies I
didn't realize that I thought now was
the best time we're trapped in the house
I mean what else you gonna do in the
house we've been playing board games but
man I know this is for real dude this is
real stuff how insane over and then
dailymed puts a picture of like naked
people spooning I guess I mean that's
that's just two people I would've
assumed I'd see it's like eight legs
when he said seven legs but that would
yeah I mean maybe NYC health have
released a graphic new memo graphic
detailing the do's and don'ts of having
sex during the corona virus pandemic
don't and their top piece of advice is
to take the matters into one's own hands
while in lockdown and to avoid orgies we
are if we are so not family-friendly at
this point I apologize but this is the
important news hey this is the New York
City they stated this they passed out so
we're just you know spreading the word
we got a cover in the news check it out
the NYC Department of Health issued a
two-page memo Saturday listing its
advice on how people can enjoy a healthy
sex life while protecting themselves
from being infected with coronavirus the
advice contained therein sent social
media into a joke spiral but also
garnered praise from those who commended
the documents inclusive nature you know
I got I got I'm sorry man we're five
were five-year-olds we're laughing at
pee-pee jokes your government was drew
the
and put out a legitimate important
document because a group of pandemic and
we're all laughing about the about potty
jokes I know but they they said funny
things they literally said you are your
safest sex partner oh no I'm sorry dude
in nine months from now there is gonna
be a baby boom yeah and then and they're
gonna crawl at Corona kids Corona kid
for real yeah YUM that's good yup the
corona generation or the corona kids
mm-hm and people are gonna be like what
does it mean oh it's because that's the
name of the the the pandemic we're all
shiny up yeah so it's funny because
there's like the baby boom generation
was what was it like after the people
got back from World War two yeah all of
a sudden we had all this money the
economy was great and start cranking out
babies mm-hmm right now I got I gotta
say man have you seen the political
compass meme where it shows all of the
different quadrants getting what they
want so the authoritarian Left is saying
the corporation's are falling apart the
libertarian left's as the environment is
healing the authoritarian rights as
governments are collapsing and then the
authoritarian right says countries are
closing their borders and then in the
middle it says my stock arenas oh no you
know what am I gonna do but here's the
thing all of this this stuff that's
happening has been a gift to the
traditional right people are gonna have
a ton of babies right the the
replacement rate was way down yeah
that's true but we're not having kids
now they're locked inside for extended
period of time and what do people do
when they're bored we all know well New
York wants to make sure they don't have
kids they're telling them to go you know
crank it out themselves
those are themselves but no matter what
they say it's gonna happen sure so it's
almost like what is this thing that just
happened where we had this ongoing
culture war where you have these you
know ultra progressive woke people who
all of a sudden became completely
irrelevant overnight you've got
feminists complaining that we're being
sent back to the 1950s I'm like yeah
like we're gonna have a baby boom yeah
it's like the 50s man it seriously is
like there's a real threat the the woke
left is becoming completely irrelevant
and obnoxious and now people are locked
inside and New Yorkers tell them like
the best ways to bang amidst an outbreak
it's crazy stuff the memo so the memo
was posted
the city governments agency website one
day before the lockdown goes into effect
for the 19 million residents of New York
State Sunday night it was titled sex and
coronavirus disease 2019 begins by
stating all New Yorkers should stay home
and minimize contact with others to
reduce the spread of kovat 19 then it
goes on to posit to the pertinent
question on many homebound New Yorkers
minds but can you have sex why would
that be a question that don't get it I
know especially especially because they
said you when you self quarantine you do
it with your friends and the people you
live with already right so I guess well
I guess there are probably lot of people
who are like tinder oh man
dating culture is just shut down yeah
bartender yeah this is no more tender
feminism no feminism social justice no
social justice the borders are being
closed asylum seekers are being turned
away manufacturing is bring bucket but
brought back to the US and now people
are gonna have a bunch of bang parties
and have babies in nine months like this
is a hard traditional right win I guess
it makes sense though it's it's nothing
to do with whether or not it's
benefiting the traditional right yeah it
has to do with whether or not certain
politics can exist outside of a crisis
it sounds like a hard reset yeah
someone's going hit the reset button I
think it's I think it's funny that we we
start by talking about the silliness of
this pamphlet but the reality is
traditionalism is getting a huge victory
through all of this yeah I guess you're
right
yeah man people are gonna be well like
we're I said the feminists are writing
op-eds complaining about it yeah that's
true so instead of offering up a
straight yes or no answer
NYC health presents a variety of tips
for how to enjoy sex and avoid spreading
kovat 19 after reminding readers about
how the corona virus spreads through
direct contact with their saliva or
mucus the agency states the virus has
been found in the home and in the stool
of people boom all you girls out there
but not yet in the male or female floors
it's like what you know if we're gonna
get D monitor those are scientific terms
it doesn't matter really I mean actually
you'd be surprised a lot of people
complained because there was a video on
YouTube where it was like a
teaching children about sex toys and
stuff okay and it was like an approved
YouTube thing really yeah dude people
are like what are you doing these kids
were like 10 years old
oh yes seriously man weird stuff well
anyway they say keeping in line with the
current social distancing advice and
lengthy hand-washing to prevent the
spread of coronavirus NYC health says
that when it comes to having sex you are
your safest partner it will not only not
spread kovat 19 especially if you wash
your hands with soap and water for at
least 20 seconds before and after sex
wait what do they call it sex or
whatever men
so basically Twitter exploded you know
choking the curb children yes it's funny
that I mean they had to do something
right they have to talk about what you
should or shouldn't be doing in this and
and we're like what how old you Adam I'm
36 I'm 34 yeah and we're sitting here
giggling like a little kitty I never
grew up I'm still waiting I'm still
waiting oh this is it
yeah yeah I was looking to see if that
dude and they actually have it here are
you gonna read it again I really do wait
yeah so this is all for the actual the
actual memo says but can you have sex
here's some tips on how to enjoy sex and
how to avoid spreading kovat 19 know how
to code 19 spreads well then show that
I'm gonna get to the good stuff here we
go number two have people with or have
sex with people close to you you are
your safest sex partner so this is the
this is the word that I guess I can't
say I mean you can't
now whatever pleasuring yourself there
we go will not spread kovin 19 you wash
your hands and when I do toys you use
with soap and water for at least 20
seconds before and after the next safest
partner is summon you live with having
close contact including sex with only a
small circle of people helps prevent
spreading kovin 19 they said no orgies
was plural only if they're in your yeah
the people you live with I guess so well
hold on is New York
telling us to bang our roommates did you
swing at me New York's advice is get off
tinder later saying get off tinder and
have you tried banging your roommate you
all live in New York you have railroad
apartments y'all live in the same room
anyway it's one big long room that
everyone walks through it's about time
to ask your roommates to put up or shut
up
if you usually meet your sex partners
online or make a living having sex since
they're taking a break from in-person
dates video dates and sexing or chat
rooms may be options for you hmm
if you usually meet your partners online
Wow tinder is over the government of New
York is flat out said no no no no online
dating don't meet strangers for sale no
no no your your best partner I don't
know why I don't know why that that
happens take care of kissing can easily
pass Cove in 1900 here's here's
important stuff I swear if you've got
kids and listen to this you need to
cover their ears right this article is
gonna better read all of this this is a
late-night show by the way
apparently all right oh goodness do I
have to read this I I'm having such a
great time [ __ ] wait hold on hold on
I can do this he's got this it is when
you kiss a butthole there you go it kind
of it might spread Kovan 19 because the
feces may enter your mouth Wow all right
thanks for letting me know New York I'll
keep that in mind
next time I kiss a butthole I'm locking
my door tonight oh but they do mention
oh wow I'm hating a great time tonight
they do mention that dental dams can
reduce the amount of feces that gets in
your mouth so just uh just consider that
I think this advice is good it is
something you should consider like any
time yeah I agree
washing up before and after is more
important
than ever no no it's important as it's
always been here we go here's my
favorite part
skip sex if you or your partner is not
feeling well yeah okay
what's the implication that you're like
going up to your partner but I don't
want to do it I don't feel well too bad
all right
only now you have to say okay we won't
then yeah but any other time with their
like I feel saying I don't know well
it's do that and then what if you or
your partner have a Cove in nineteen
avoid having sex okay I I will all right
if you start to feel unwell you may be
about to develop symptoms of kovat 19
which includes fever cough sore throat
and shortness of breath if you or your
partner has a medical condition that can
lead that can lead to more severe kovat
19 you may also want to skip sex medical
conditions includes lung disease heart
disease diabetes cancer or a weakened
immune system okay I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be honest like they have to do it
because there are a lot of dumb people
out there right you know what it's like
oh and not only that there's people that
don't care about any of this and there's
going out and having their orgies in
anyway and there are people that need
that right now we're ordered to sell to
isolate and instead they went on the
beach start chugging beer after about
through their bodies butt cracks you
know it's funny but it's it spreads and
feces so you but chuggers out there well
no but listen listen the people who went
on spring break and we're like we're not
gonna be quarantined yeah I can
understand not want to be quarantined
yeah but you did you really have to chug
off your friends but like pouring the
beer down their crack and drinking it
it's like almost like you want to get
sick yeah yeah it's it's it's it's a
degree of absurdity that goes beyond
just them to find quarantine yeah give
it a big middle finger feels and purpose
yeah giving a big mess yeah screw you
yeah they think so until they get it and
then and they're like woe is me I have
it I gotta admit I do feel kind of bad
making fun of them for this
cuz you know you you gotta put it out
you know I
what our lady about New York yeah NYC
right oh no I'm not making fun NYC I
mean we're making fun of the people that
they needed to put this out for that's
what if you if you lick a but you might
get a feces in your mouth I didn't know
that
thanks New York for letting me know I'm
pretty sure there are people who didn't
know that yep it's true all the but
chuggers are like oh no I don't get it
man but when you're surrounded by a
bunch of morons you don't care you know
I mean yeah so it was like it's like a
human centipede thing they all form a
circle of butt chugging it's amazing now
granted what I saw wasn't a huge ring it
was like four or five people but like
hey do your thing I guess just let me
know if you do this I can avoid you I
don't want you like talking to me and
then like spitting on accent and like is
that like kazoo lies out and you're hi
hi nice to meet you hey by the way do
you if you ever butt chugged or have you
butt chugged in the past 23 more
specific 24 months when you go to the
minute alright I'm leaving when you go
to your next business meeting you say hi
my name is Bill nice to meet you Jim
great to meet you Jim just a couple of
questions have you ever bent over and
poured a beard on the crack of another
person's button then drank it I'm if the
answer is yes get out of my office
do you have hand sanitizer Ferb we just
shook hands I would like to know no you
definitely asked that question before
you shake your hands huh yeah hi Bill
I'm done can I let me just ask you a
question before yes according to the New
York tattoo at New York City Health
Commission that's entirely possible that
you may have licked someone's butt and
gotten feces in your mouth yeah so
actually I watched uh you-know-who Blatt
you ever hear of black pigeon speaks no
um he's a youtuber and he put out a
video about Japan because I think he's
in Japan yeah and he was talking about
how they did not have a serious you know
they got hit by it they know with it
really quickly another kind of okay okay
they don't shake hands about mmm they
wear masks yeah I mean when they get
sick they don't wanna get other people
sick so they wear masks yeah they don't
shake hands
they don't hug and kiss and it was funny
he said they don't like to be touched I
thought that was funny it's like don't
touch me
you're invading my personal yeah but but
Americans are on tinder all the time you
know Italians are kissing each other all
the time
true so it's no surprise I mean it's
kind of stereotypical how Italy got so
bad yeah because they on the cheeks
double both sides they walk up they grab
your hand they start rubbing you all
over and squeezing and then licking your
face and it's just like bone and you're
sick and Americans we lick products on
the show we out drink beer out buttholes
and Wow you know what man
so that's free dance that's freedom baby
pros and cons man you gotta take the
good with the bad
I like my freedom too much tell someone
not to drink beer off someone's butt and
it's true but if you want me to pay for
that if you pains me to go yes you're
right if do you want me to pay for their
health care we got to have another
conversation it's also true yeah thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you